now I know what some of you are gonna be
thinking if you're in the USA you're
gonna be like oh yeah
Tintin it just came out and so Jeremy's
doing a video and that's just normal if
you're outside the USA you're gonna be
like dude get with the game just came
out months ago and for you it did but
for us it just came out this weekend so
but this is what it feels like to get
movies late this sucks I hate it
[Music]
the adventures of tintin or so the
adventures of tintin I can sum it up for
you right here producer Peter Jackson
director Steven Spielberg nice recipe
for a winning combination if ever there
was one so The Adventures of Tintin
stars Tintin and it follows him and his
dog got his dog and then go on an
adventure to find a treasure and of
course there's this other guy who wants
this treasure too and you don't want him
to get it because he's a dick so now
it's a race of course the villain knows
more about the treasure than Tenten does
that makes Tintin our underdog you know
that's why we're rooting for him and at
a point Tintin runs across Captain
Haddock and now they team up and they're
going to find this treasure and I would
argue that Captain Haddock becomes less
of a secondary sidekick character and
more of a second lead character which is
really cool I like that they both share
an awesomeness now Captain Haddock is
played by Andy Serkis know Gollum we all
love and know Gollum and Captain Haddock
made for some really good comedy relief
sometimes the comedy in this movie kind
of swung towards some slapstick I didn't
really like that as much like sometimes
there are things that happen in this
movie you're like that that's not
realistic that wouldn't happen that's
like a cartoon but unrealistic slapstick
type stuff that wouldn't actually work
starts to happen it starts making you
see it more like a cartoon and less like
a movie it starts to become a bummer but
it's not everywhere in the movie but
it's at places but it has some absurdly
awesome action sequences I mean they're
running the clock you know they're
trying to get away from this disaster
they're trying to outrun whatever I mean
at a point in the trailer when I saw
this
[Music]
bang
I was like yeah that's uncharted and I
will sum it up for you like this this
movie is like uncharted the young Nathan
Drake chronicles it worked for this
movie and the cinematography is just
nuts 3d is really good too if you like
3d action sequences this movie was made
for it and it's produced by Peter
Jackson so you know he's gonna be like
none of this mediocre 3d you give me the
best I don't know if he can talk to
Spielberg's like that but you know it
didn't happened so cool character is a
fun adventure that reminds me of
uncharted great action sequences a good
treasure hunt movie that's what you're
in for with Tintin I would say I would
buy this movie on blu-ray great fun and
good for the whole family if you have a
family you can take him to it even
though there are people who get sliced
up and died with pirate swords it's just
CGI ketchup tell your kids that so your
favorite treasure hunting adventure what
would it be comment below let me know if
you say Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
bad things happen and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]